>> Bret: TREY YINGST LIVE IN
THE L.A. NEWSROOM.
THANK YOU.
A DECLASSIFIED U.S. INTELLIGENCE
REPORT RELEASED TODAY STATES
THAT SAUDI ARABIA’S CROWN
PRINCE WAS AWARE OF AND LIKELY
APPROVED THE KILLING OF
U.S.-BASED JOURNALIST
JAMAL KHASHOGGI.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" WRITER WAS
MURDERED INSIDE THE SAUDI
CONSULATE IN ISTANBUL IN 2018.
SAUDI ARABIA SAYS THE REPORT HAS
UNJUSTIFIED AND INACCURATE
CONCLUSIONS.
KHASHOGGI WAS A CRITIC OF CROWN
PRINCE CONSOLIDATION OF POWER.
LET’S TALK ABOUT THE KHASHOGGI
REPORT, THE U.S. AIR STRIKES IN
SYRIA COMING IN THEN EXTRACTS
WITH -- STEPS WITH IRAN AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
A FORMER NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE
MANAGER FOR IRAN AND A FORMER
CIA EXPERT.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
>> MY PLEASURE.
>> Bret: LET’S START WITH THE
STRIKES.
IN THE ADMINISTRATION SAYING
THAT IT IS ESSENTIALLY A WARNING
SHOT, YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
STRATEGIC IMPORTANCE OF IT OR
THE CRITICISM THAT THEY ARE
TAKING FOR IT, WHAT ABOUT THE
STRIKE?
>> SO LET ME EXPLAIN WHAT HAS
HAPPENED HERE.
IN THIS CASE COMING OF THE
UNITED STATES HAS EITHER BEEN
ATTACKED OR RECEIVED INFORMATION
OF AN ATTACK AND HAS RESPONDED
WITH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE WARNINGS
TO IRAN NOT TO UNDERTAKE THOSE
ATTACKS.
IRAN FAILED TO DO SO, SO THEN WE
RESPONDED WITH AN ACTION THAT
DEMONSTRATES THAT WE ARE NOT
GOING TO ALLOW THEM TO
DESTABILIZE A ROCK.
BUT WE ARE DEMONSTRATING OUR
POWER AND OUR INTELLIGENCE AND
OUR CAPACITY TO STRIKE THOSE WHO
ARE BEHIND THE ATTACK.
HERE’S THE QUESTION, WILL IRAN
RESPOND BY GETTING THE MESSAGE
OR JUST TAKING IT UP ANOTHER
STEP ON THE ESCALATORY LADDER TO
TEST OUR WILL IN THE LONG RUN?
IT’S GOING YES, IN THE MEANTIME
AS THIS IS HAPPENING WITH TREY,
THE ADMINISTRATION IS MAKING
MOVES TO GET BACK INTO SOME
NUCLEAR DEAL, THERE WERE REPORTS
THAT SOME MEMBERS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION WERE KIND OF
TALKING TO THE IRANIANS
INCLUDING SECRETARY CARRIE HAS
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WAS IN
OFFICE, THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT AND
WHAT IT MEANS FOR THE STRATEGIC
MIDDLE EAST GEOPOLITICALLY?
>> WELL, FIRST, DIPLOMACY IS
ALWAYS A GOOD THING.
THIS SAID, ENGAGEMENT THUS FAR
WITH IRAN HAS NOT BEEN PRODUCING
I BELIEVE WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION SEEKS.
IN ADDITION TO ARRIVING WITHIN
THE VIPs THAT THEY WOULD
ENGAGE AND RETURN TO THE NUCLEAR
DEAL IF POSSIBLE, THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN SOME
PATHETIC TWO IRANIAN REQUESTS
FOR FUNDING TO THE IMS.
LOOK WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN
RESPONSE, ATTACKS ON U.S. TROOPS
IN IRAQ, AND ATTACK TODAY ON
ISRAELI VESSELS IN THE GULF
MONMOUTH, WITH THE IRG C.
IRAN’S REFUSAL TO COOPERATE WITH
THE IAEA.
THUS FAR IRAN IS TESTING OUR
FORTITUDE SEEING HOW FAR IT CAN
PUSH THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IN
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY FOR
ADDITIONAL CONCESSIONS.
>> Bret: I WANT TO READ FROM
THIS INTELLIGENCE REPORT ABOUT
SAUDI.
THE ASSESSING THE SAUDI
GOVERNMENT TO RULE IN THE
KILLING OF JAMAAL COCO SHOOK --
JAMAL KHASHOGGI.
PRINCE APPROVED IN A STYLE
DELETE NECK AND STUMBLE TURKEY,
THE CROWN PRINCE VIEWED AS A
THREAT TO THE KINGDOM AND HAVE
BROADLY SUPPORTED USING VIOLENT
MEASURES IF NECESSARY TO SILENCE
HIM.
YOU KNOW, I ASKED TO THE FOREIGN
MINISTER ABOUT THIS BACK IN
OCTOBER OF 2018, HERE IS THE
EXCHANGE AHEAD.
>> IN AN AUTHORITARIAN
GOVERNMENT, AND YOU ARE SAYING
THAT THE CROWN PRINCE DID NOT
KNOW ABOUT THIS AT ALL EVEN
THOUGH THERE ARE MEMBERS OF THE
15 PERSON TEAM THAT ARE CLOSELY
ALIGNED WITH HIM?
>> FIRST OF ALL, WE ARE A
MONARCHY, WE HAVE CHECKS AND
BALANCES IN OUR SYSTEMS, WE HAVE
INDIVIDUALS WHO DID THIS OUTSIDE
OF THE AUTHORITY.
THIS IS A MISTAKE, THIS IS A
CRIMINAL ACT AND THOSE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT WILL BE
PUNISHED.
>> TO THE ORIGINAL QUESTION, DID
THE CROWN PRINCE KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT IT IF THERE WERE PEOPLE
CLOSELY TIED TO HIM INVOLVED IN
THE OPERATION?
>> THERE ARE MULTIPLE PEOPLE
CLOSELY TIED TO HIM AND IN THE
OPERATION, PICTURES OF SOME
SECURITY OFFICERS WHO WERE A
PART OF THE SECURITY DETAIL FROM
TIME TO TIME, BUT THIS IS
NORMAL.
IT WAS IN OPERATION, IT WAS A
GROUP OPERATION.
>> Bret: SO THIS A
ADMINISTRATION CHOOSING TO
DECLASSIFY THIS REPORT NOT
SEEING ANY STRICT PUNISHMENTS
FOR MBS, THE CROWN PRINCE.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
>> WELL, THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
CHEWED STEVE -- ACHIEVED TODAY
SEVERAL THINGS.
THIS IS ANOTHER STEP IN
RELATIONS WITH SAUDI ARABIA IN
RECENT WEEKS WE HAVE SEEN THE
PRESIDENT DENIED THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK WITH THE CROWN PRINCE
HIMSELF, THEY ENDED IN AN ARMS
DEAL.
THEY HAVE ALSO CUT BACK ON
SAUDI ARABIA REGARDING YEMEN,
BUT TO THIS MAKES IT VERY CLEAR,
U.S. INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
BELIEVES OR ASSESSES THAT THE
CROWN PRINCE PLAYED A
DECISION-MAKING ROLE IN THE
FACTION.
I SHOULD NOTE THAT THIS REPORT
PROVIDES NO EVIDENCE AND APPEARS
TO BE BASED ON INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY’S UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
SAUDI ARABIA WORKS LESS THAN THE
ACTUAL INFORMATION.
I SHOULD ALSO NOTE THAT DESPITE
THIS REPORT, THEY ARE BEEN
ROUTINE DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN THE
UNITED STATES LEADERSHIP AND
SAUDI ARABIA ON MULTIPLE
SECURITY ISSUES WITHIN THE LAST
FEW WEEKS.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE, THE
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE, THE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF HAVE ALL
ENGAGED IN COUNTERPARTS AND A
VERY INFLUENTIAL SAUDI
AMBASSADOR TO THE UNITED STATES
IN A ROUTINE CONTACT WITH THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND THE
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL.
SO THE RESET CONTINUES, BUT THE
BROADER RELATIONS BETWEEN THE
UNITED STATES AND THROUGH GOD
ONE ISSUE OF IMPORTANCE TO EACH
OF OUR COUNTRIES DOES GO ON.
>> Bret: AND JUST QUICKLY,
OBVIOUSLY THE LAST A
ADMINISTRATION USE THE GULF
STATE TO DO IT A DIFFERENT WAY
TO MIDDLE EAST PEACE, AND WE ARE
HAVING SOME SUCCESS, OBVIOUSLY
SIGNIFICANT SUCCESS, DOES THIS
CHANGE THAT?
DOES THIS ADMINISTRATION TAKE AN
OPPOSITE VIEW WITH NOT ONLY
IRAN, BUT THE GOAL STATES?
>> NOT REGARDING THE GOAL STATES
AND ISRAEL, THIS ADMINISTRATION
WILL FURTHER LOOK AT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WHICH WAS
SIGNIFICANT AND HISTORIC.
BUT THAT WILL TAKE SOME TIME TO
DEVELOP.
IN THE ADMINISTRATION WILL PUSH
THE GULF STATES TO ENGAGE IRAN
AND THEY WILL BE RELUCTANT TO DO
SO SINCE THEY ARE UNDER A
ROUTINE ATTACK BY THE COOK FORCE
FORCE.
>> NORMAN RULE, WE REALLY